hello and welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we are looking at some pretty cool stuff
today
yeah look at that match dude look at
that freaking match man Little Green Men
invading your home Battlegrounds here to
blow your minds
people we're back we're going to be
taking a look at a spooky film called
polargeist which has a practical effect
shot in it that was super high stakes
involved not something exploding but
imploding that's a slow implode wait
what are we seeing we are also going to
be taking a look at one of the most
underrated sci-fi films of all time
starring an incredible cast called
Sunshine a the title
shot all right let's get into it
[Music]
woo who this is so cool dude take a
little walk this is winga he did this on
behalf of insta 360 I believe using the
insta 36 60 flow not a sponsor just a
[Music]
fact take us through the train I love
this shot so much it's so cool and that
was a relatively straightforward
transition just some simple masking and
the same sort of camera move uh
this that's what I didn't get I don't
understand what happened there he must
be stretching it oh I see it now I see
it now I see he's stretching the footage
and then compositing it back in yeah but
it's so cool to add those little
compositing flourishes cuz it just makes
it magic Wow how do you think they did
such a consistent job on those radial
moves at the beginning I mean I bet they
had a rope and they just had a big rope
and he was holding the rope and they
just walked along and so that's how they
knew the exact Arc for it cuz you take a
rope and it's not going to change
distance so they're able to basically
have points where the camera guy should
walk and they probably just step by step
just like take a step and the actor just
kind of faces camera take another step
actor faces camera again and just slowly
do that and then you just go through and
you take out the frames you need fast
forward the footage so you take got all
of the stuff of them getting into
position cuz it's I think it's still a
video clip but it doesn't look like the
quality changes like you can tell a
difference between a photo and a video
frame and it looks like the same so this
photo are you sure it's photo no I think
you're right I think this is all video I
think it's video cuz it'd be easier just
to like get into position and just
record the whole thing and you have all
of the frames necessary you just cut out
what you don't need maybe you're right
does he say at the end he kind of gives
a little breakdown at the end of this
yep step at a time Ren's having PTSD
flashback right now and I'm willing to
bet they're just shooting video he's
just recording one long take for this
whole thing yeah you can see how they're
getting because it's a consistent Rhythm
they're getting stuff done you know
there's the string there it is that's
the string it's such a good idea they
left the string in the shot and painted
it out on the back end okay I was
thinking they would like just get it and
then like remove the string but it's so
easy to remove a string yep no it's
great approach man this was the most
challenging one I'm sure because holding
that holding an arm out consistently is
impossible I remember when this came out
cuz people kept sending it to me for us
to review on the show so I'm glad we're
finally doing that dude this is legit
yeah it had to be done hey guys it's
Jordan and I am super excited to talk to
you about today's sponsor co-pilot
co-pilot is a personalized flexible
workout program and it's an app that you
can have on your phone it also comes
with a personal trainer dedicated to
your Fitness needs you can talk to your
trainer about what your fitness goals
are what your experience level in
Fitness is what equipment you have
available to you and your personal
trainer will take all of that into
consideration and create you a
personalized fitness plan just for you
if your legs are super sore from the
week before so you want to focus on your
upper body the next week you can tell
them that and they will refocus your
workout for exactly what you need at
that moment say the holidays are coming
up you're going to be somewhere else and
you don't have any equipment your
trainer will make you a personalized
workout based off of being on the floor
or a bench or anything that is around
you I'm not kidding if there is a big
rock in your backyard they will make you
a workout plan that can have you
squatting The Rock and and throwing the
Rock and that is my favorite part about
this app I can be in a hotel room I can
be outside or I can be in my gym I'm
still going to get the same intensity
and Care there's also a bunch of
wonderful inapp features my personal
favorite is putting on my Apple watch
and having it pair to my phone while I'm
doing the workout it knows how fast my
heart is beating it knows how many
calories I've been burning and also it
knows if I'm doing some workouts in
correctly if you're doing a lift and
you're going too high they'll say hey
don't go so high at the top it's little
things like that that make it feel like
you have a personal trainer right next
to you the beautiful thing about this
app is you're never actually on a
personal trainer's time you can do this
workout at 3:00 a.m. or 3:00 p.m. it's
your schedule you call the shots so I
love co-pilot and with the holidays
coming up maybe you want to start
getting into the fitness game a little
more or maybe you want to get a head
start on those New Year's resolutions
click the link in the description below
or scan the QR code for 14 days free
with the expert fitness and health coach
now back to
react
they're here have you guys heard of
poltergeist have you watched Poltergeist
I thought it was polter gist the polter
[Music]
GEOS oh look at that Dolly Zoom that
Dolly Zoom mhm oh it just keeps zooming
yeah it's still going wow run they do a
slightly more nuanced version here which
I really like it's I can't reach it
can't reach it can't reach it just
kidding I can reach it and then like she
accelerates while the camera like stops
zooming okay that was pretty cool I like
that effect there help
me wow
Texas
switch see I saw her leg I saw her leg
right there ohow oh you did wow good
spot Ren so what is a Texas switch it's
where you have a stunt person do a stunt
and then in the shot without cutting the
regular actor comes back in so it's like
you have a stuntman fall behind a couch
then the regular actor jumps back out it
makes it seem like it's the same person
the whole time that's scrambling out of
the way it's so funny cuz if he had just
stayed still no one would register it
yeah cuz we're attracted to the motion
of that leg being pulled if he just sat
perfectly still we'd ignore the Le in
frame I think this shot almost didn't
work watching it multiple times now
there's like there's Shadows moving I
think there was like a boom mic shadow
in the yeah I was what that I thought
that was the railing of the stair I was
just giv giv him that wait but it moves
I know I was like oh maybe the camera's
moving like that's a boom M or something
you know it's like it's this close to
not working now you guys watched the
light and Magic documentary right yes
dude
so cool wait is this this is that movie
what do you mean this is that movie with
that shot dude that shot dude that
shot
oh move the
bodies oh and then it turned into a wait
was it always a comp shot here was the
previous shot a comp
shot that's a slow implosion wait what
are we seeing it's like a explosion dude
there it goes I love that we're
basically the town's people right
now I was expecting an actual like
implosion but this is like a pole like
almost as if they have a bunch of wires
connected to pieces of the inside of the
house and it's just all pulling it down
a drain wow look at you just calling the
shots perfectly wait is that how they
did it well he's missing one element he
missing one element there's a few things
going on so yeah they built a big
miniature of the house they had wired
connected to everything on the inside
and it was all going down to a big
funnel which is also a big vacuum and
then they also had a shotguns strapped
up above this model and the camera right
above it and the idea was say go start
pulling turn that giant vacuum on so it
all pulls it in and if it doesn't go
blop blop with the shotguns to break it
apart and get it sucked into the the
vacuum thing this sick the model cost
$225,000 to build back then so it was
one of those things where it's like
we're going to do this once it's got to
work no one's ever tried it before for
we have no idea how this is actually
going to work there was one small error
that is that the shot was slightly
underexposed because they shot it at 300
frames per second imagine the pressure
you get one take there's two men with
shotgun just aimed at the model and
they're like go and you're just yanking
it through a hole and men are shooting
it and then you just you get what you
get and you move on you're like all
right this is what I got it's going in
the movie we're not done yet with
Poltergeist you got to move the bod keep
it keep it running Christian keep it
coming
this is polter GS 3 oh my gosh it should
have been polter G poter G and polter GS
dud that's so
good oh
gosh oh
cool hold up excuse me yeah I don't know
how they did that one actually wait my
guess on how they did so there's there's
a few things happening here first off
it's a real mirror she puts her hand
against the mirror then it cuts to this
shot where I think there's holes in the
mirror and real fingers come out and
grab her hand it's such a good effect is
so legit you can kind of see I think a
hole on her right hand there oh at the
top of the yeah but it's like it's so
subtle and you're not expecting fingers
to come out of a mirror cuz other than
that that's a legit mirror so then my
guess I don't know maybe maybe our
guesses are the same prosthetic fingers
on her actual hand there and she's just
up against an actual proper mirror and
she's rigged up to wires and her hands
are getting pulled up so that's a really
good guess but her hands really stick I
think I figured it out actually oh
unless okay unless the entire mirror
itself is raised yep wow so there's a
hole in the floor and the whole mirror
is just down in the floor and to raise
her they just lifted the whole mirror
yep so she's holding on to like
something there and the whole thing goes
up that's great I have never seen this
trick before that was pretty great but
yeah the reason why this works so well
is because you don't know that the
mirror is moving and there's an implied
hole in the mirror that is changing
that's impossible magic trick works yep
there's a lot more stuff that we're
looking at here that's not on YouTube
but guess what it is on quarter
digital.com extended episodes check it
out you can get a free twoe
[Music]
trial this one man this is fun dude okay
so Stephen King is a relatively
well-known author who Stephen King
he's he does horror he's he's on the
come up okay you'll hear about him soon
this is a TNT creation based on his
short film Battlegrounds about a Hitman
who kills a toy maker but those toys
they ain't just
toys this movie sounds amazing they are
wow I love that he's yeah he's going
after them with a pistol I love it so
much they're just like little LEDs that
are flashing into the couch oh no bab
thirsty wa he's going to make
war it's a lot of special effects for
shooting at a couch dude can you imagine
if you're taking cover from this giant
shooting bullets the size of you yeah oh
my gosh
yeah yeah they are oh
no oh no they're all dead no but are
those people this is just one big set
whoa this is R okay hold up this is a
comp shot in order to fake that really
shallow depth feeli that you get when
you film small stuff but those are wait
wait this is actually really good the
heck it doesn't have any right to be so
good it's
amazing look at that match dude look at
that freaking match
man that's great so
satisfying oh that's
sick so obviously there's a lot of
incredible comp work going on here but I
think the unsung hero here is the camera
work they're shooting everything on set
here with a camera that's you know maybe
3T off the ground so then they're
filming all these army men on a blue
screen that matches the onset
perspective perfectly and you have to
scale that camera move down in a way
that's not the easiest thing to do it's
not super hard but it's so easy to mess
up and I've seen it messed up so many
times so they shot the majority of
principal I think all of principal
actually in Australia and then chased it
in LA on blue screen with these guys but
yeah the matching of the lighting the
matching of the camera the scale
matching like all incredibly well done
when you're filming something in
miniature you have a really shallow
depth of fi imagine like zooming in with
your lens you know want something that's
really tiny it's far away like anything
that's a few inches behind that focal
plane is blurry and same with the stuff
in front of it so when you're filming
people you can't film a whole person
with that shallow up the field like
cameras to do that just don't exist
actually a guy did build a large format
like one foot by I've been really
wanting to rebuild that by the way so
that one would do this effect but hey
DIY perks release the schematics for
that you haven't done it you said you
would I've been waiting you're totally
right they filmed all separate plates
comped them all together added the depth
of field on the back end to match the
focal plane all really masterfully done
what's really cool about this is all the
props are full scale so those Jeeps that
they're lifting full scale and they
rubberized them so that they looked
obviously the part because you need the
smaller version to match the bigger
version if if there's any sort of
cohesion visually this has no right to
be as good as it is yeah this is when
visual effects is not an afterthought
this is when it is a part of the process
from pre-production on and this is what
it can
do we have a payload to deliver to the
heart of our nearest
star that star is dying okay have you
guys seen the movie Sunshine yes many
times Sunshine is one of the films that
like surprisingly a lot of people have
not seen and it's one of the best space
movies in my opinion it's really
[Music]
good is that Captain America yeah so the
cast of this is crazy we got Chris Evans
Benedict Wong Michelle yo kilan Murphy
what they're looking at right now is the
transit of mercury across the Sun so
that little dot going across is mercury
wow NPC did all of the effects for this
movie there's like 750 shots in this
movie and the bulk of the work is
creating the CG sun and also the
spaceship itself and the spaceship is
Super Rad cuz it's essentially just a
giant Shield that's a mile wide that is
protecting the actual behind it
dude every shot of the sun was actually
Handmade by the team at MP DC but it was
inspired by all the imagery that they
would get from NASA and pretty much the
entire sun was simulated with fluids in
Maya what wow no way in a in a 2d form
sort of
thing yeah this is awesome W the scale
wo wao wo it's stretching no we're just
orbiting it oh we're orbiting it oh my
gosh my brain exactly but that's what I
love about that shot is that like it's
kind of a misdirection like what's going
on and then you realize the scale of
everything is so massive that the camera
is actually just orbiting around that's
just how big the sun is wow it's like a
freaking gold dress blue dress
thing like I saw it I saw it just
speeding across the Horizon gosh they do
such a wonderful job showcasing scale
and there's the edge oh manross the
other side of that is death yeah and the
brightness like the handling of
brightness in this movie is so good it's
hard to film bright things to the camera
cuz it just turns white you know it's
like who's to say that's bright it's
just white on your TV screen and like
how rolls off into color it's like all
those things are like what trigger you
to think it's like bright or hot like
think of like a lightsaber right it's
white and then it's like a color fuzz
and we see that as glow this is actually
the second mission Humanity sent to the
Sun the first one several years earlier
they lost contact with but they went and
found it cuz they were getting a
distress Beacon from that other ship so
they overlapped their Shields and
detached the ship to go over to it oh
that's cool that looks like gold that
looks amazing gold isn't the easiest
thing to render in CG it's metal is like
a weird thing the way metal reflects
light is not like a normal reflective
surface but they nailed it here so most
surfaces when they reflect will simply
reflect the light that comes back at you
know that comes at them so like my arm
is absorbing you know wavelengths except
for the orange light and then it's kind
of shooting that back at camera but as
you get more towards the edges of my
Armor gets shinier or if it's sweatier
it just kind of reflects all light metal
does an interesting thing where the
light that it reflects takes on the
color of the metal so it's it's kind of
weird metal like change it like tints
the color the reflections the opening of
this movie first off it's the Fox Search
light logo reversed so that's how it
normally starts and then it it reveals
the Fox Search light logo but here it
actually starts there and goes backwards
so that it focuses on the sun that's at
the beginning of the shot that's cool
but then the sun turns into the Sun from
the
movie our son is dying look at that sun
mankind faces Extinction wait a minute
is that a sun a sun what else could be
be perfectly round and that bright any
[Applause]
flashlight any flashlight rotate around
it rotate around it I think it's a
flashlight it's not a flashlight it is
the
sun it's a flashlight oh it's the ship
it's the ship dude God you can see the
mirrors all their like stepped formation
is such a cool sh
awesome oh yeah what a shot title it's
the title
[Laughter]
shot go watch this movie on YouTube
right now it's
free yeah as a reminder click the link
below or scan the QR code to get a
14-day free trial with co-pilot do you
have any recommendations for super
underappreciated and underrated films
that have some pretty impressive visual
effects leave a comment down below
because I need some more stuff to
research almost all of you have
subscribed like in the last react
episode we got 200 subscribers out of it
out of like a million views 200 people
subscribed and it's not that other ones
aren't subscribing it's that all of you
are really nice and you did consider
subscribing and you did so thank you we
really appreciate it here gosh imagine
being the person who's not subscribed
right now be awes I was trying to make
this not a subscription I'm just saying
you could just they could just fix it
just fix it real quick and then you're
in then you get to be a part of this
moment just real quick yeah you can
rewind and watch the video after you do
it